[MUSIC]
Amit is asking a question.
After or
when having the idea in my mind, what
is the best practice tool to apply the
idea, and implement it, and execute it?
Do you just start a company right away?
Do you ask your parents?
>> No, when we did,
don't ask your parents.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Your parents are always going to
validate you.
That's a great idea.
Never ask your parents if
it's a good idea or not.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Ask your spouse.
>> You have great parents.
I have great parents,
but don't ask them.
Because they're always going to say,
that's wonderful honey, it's great.
They love you unconditionally,
whether it's a good idea or
a bad idea,
they're going to say it's great.
>> You're saying a spouse
is the opposite.
>> Spouse is the opposite.
>> [LAUGH]
>> They should be,
they should be truthful.
That's what you want
is the great partner.
So now it's start with the idea,
and in Nest,
it took almost a whole year
before we started the company.
The way that it first started was,
how might I think I could solve
this problem technically.
So is it, do I have enough the pieces,
do I know enough of the things.
And I said, yeah I know that.
>> Yeah.
>> Because I had enough
experience of that.
So you first had to research enough
about what you think would be built in.
Then after that,
you start researching the market.
So you have to remember when
you're disrupting an industry.
And if you have something
dramatically different,
if you have disruptive technology,
then you can change a stagnated market.
>> Yes.
>> The way that I've seen it is that,
you have to start with the idea,
what are you changing, and
you have to take bold steps in terms
of making something and trying it.
Now you have to test.
Lots of testing.
So, you would make something and
then you would go to a,
some of the industry leaders, or
some of the people you really trust.
Who are knowledgable about a given area.
And, you'd say what do you think,
what do you think?
And, then you would start to set
your risk level based on how big
the market is.
I think the way the world changes,
is not by people being safe, but
by challenging expectations.
Challenging the conventional wisdom.
And if you want to change the world, you
need to get out the area of safeness.
[MUSIC]